microsoft tech director mike ibarra has
spoken up to respond to criticisms of
Windows 10 PC gaming features and has
made a promise to provide a fix for
vertical synchronization I'm Lucy and
welcome to this gamespot news updates
after ibarra tweeted about time bending
action game quantum break looking
incredible on xbox one and pc someone
responded by asking about sli and
crossfire support which some have raised
concerns about on Windows 10 ibarra
clarified that SLI and crossfire are
already enabled on Windows 10 it's just
that individual games need to support it
on the subject of framerate ibarra
acknowledged Windows 10 shortcomings and
vowed that a fix for vsync specifically
is in the works leave hours comments
follow those from top xbox dog Phil
Spencer he recently said that he's heard
the concerns some PC gamers have about
Windows 10 and promised microsoft has
plans to improve of course it's possible
that Microsoft will discuss its new pc
gaming plans next month at the game
developers conference Microsoft are
hosting a session titled the future of
Xbox game development for windows during
which new information may be divulged
another session and game developer
success and opportunities with gaming on
windows will be hosted by ID at Xbox
director Chris Charla so what do you
make a V borrowers promise and how are
you finding gaming on Windows 10 be sure
to let me know in the comments below or
come by me on Twitter I met Lucy James
games for the latest xbox and pc news
keep it gamespot
you